foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
grandpa is freaking out this morning
we've made it
[Music]
weighted decision
from the jury the anonymous jury in the
E Gene Carroll rape and defamation trial
Donald Trump seems to suspect so and
he's also attacking Ronnie D
meatball pudding fingers down in Florida
attacking Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis said
this morning doing a horrible horrible
job of impersonating Trump his Trump
impersonation is getting worse and worse
and worse that [__] weirdo I'm
talking about Ron DeSantis it's a weirdo
I don't know if you know that
whoo baby what else did we get in the
news oh
Darth Vader Jr Strikes Back
not only does Liz Cheney make a
commercial absolutely
wadding up Donald Trump and dunking him
in the treasonous trash
but she's gonna air this thing on CNN
during his his little town hall in New
Hampshire
I guess that's that's the [__] news I
don't know we're gonna show you this ad
from Liz Cheney it's [__] hilarious
oh man I love when [__] sandwiches eat
[__] [__] sandwiches a lot of people a
lot of people are
um worried you know about like
uh at least you know oh do we support
Liz Cheney do we not I mean when she's
attacking Donald Trump you definitely
have to
um but
when
um
when you have to defend her you don't
have to do that you don't have to do
that Liz Cheney is no uh um a hero of
liberal democracy just because she did
the bare minimum okay the bare minimum
is that she defended democracy from a
wannabe dictator who tried to overthrow
it and then she told the truth come on
man come on that's not a high bar really
honestly her and Adam King singer just
met the bare minimum
that's it that's it that's all they did
was beat meet the bare minimum and they
paid huge consequences for telling the
bare minimum truth
I mean it's not complicated Liz Cheney's
know again Liz Cheney is no [__] hero
for Liberty our liberal democracy at
that for that stretch of the matter
she's got a horrible voting record as a
member of Congress horrible just go look
at it against women against women's
health care
against migrants coming to this country
and working
I mean she's not she's no [__] cup of
tea right this isn't someone who is the
on the Democratic side
of the aisle at all but hey you know
what when she gets her sword out and
starts flailing around and it catches
the face of Donald Trump a couple times
I'm excited about it hell yeah I love
when Liz Cheney Donald Trump and Ron
DeSantis are in a fight why wouldn't you
and this morning not only that there
must be some movement in the Jack Smith
case
uh because Donald Trump is attacking
Bill Barr again Bill Barr was um has
spoke out against Trump again uh maybe
we'll pull that clip where Bill Barr is
basically saying Donald Trump is a
[__] idiot
I mean not not in those many words
that's what I would say but Bill Barr
basically saying this guy's a [__]
dummy we should not have this gay as
president but I'll vote for him if he's
a nominee no problem
that makes Bill Barr some sort of great
political operative get the [__] out of
here he's also attacking Karl Rove this
morning in the same little ditty the
guys the guy same [__] different diaper
today with Grandpa poopy pants down
there Mar-A-Lago you know the Cheeto
does cue in honor but here's the thing
is today you know I don't normally go to
his statements a lot sometimes we show
him on here because they're newsworthy
but I think his freakouts this morning
are a hundred percent a hundred percent
newsworthy and the reason why is because
you can feel the pressure in him like
you can feel
um how his anxiety
it's it's palpable in his little truce
this morning in his truce his truth post
this morning
it's gonna be exciting folks
um this Republican primary is is gonna
heat up now I was you know at first
glance when CNN said that they would
have Donald Trump on right
and it's like you dumb [__]
but now that I'm thinking about this
think about that I I'm not so sure this
isn't a bad thing right CNN is going to
give him a platform to just spew
absolute lunacy right to get it all
right out there to show exactly what and
who he is
in front of a huge audience that
wouldn't normally love him right I mean
CNN is definitely trying to capitalize
on Fox news's woes with the with the
Dominion settlement that they had to
have which by the way I'd like to say
Fox News is doing just fine since they
fired Tucker Carlson but where is Tucker
Carlson where is this [__] I
thought he was I thought he was the most
popular [__] commentator in the world
and the audience would follow him and
there's no way Tucker's not where's
Tucker where the [__] is Tucker where
you at buddy
anyways Fox News is doing fine with that
Tucker I told you that would happen it's
about the 8 P.M spot it's about selling
ads on that 8 PM spot they want creative
control back but let's go back to what I
was talking about about CNN CNN is
trying to get their audience they want
the Fox News audience that's what they
want now good bad and different however
you want to look at it the good news is
is it looks like CNN knew
but at least Cheney would buy ad time
okay so I'm not I'm not gonna say that
CNN's business model is horrible because
they've already made a huge [__]
political ad by just by having Donald
Trump dumb ass on their [__] on their
cameras I mean all of a sudden Liz Janie
is gonna buy time who no God knows how
much CNN charged her
and this the Super PAC that she's that
she's using
um to
to place this at but it's a great ad I
love the ad I can't I can't wait to hold
this against Liz Cheney one of these
days
don't don't get it twisted Darth Vader
Jr is not your friend she's not your
friend Liz Cheney is not liberal
democracy's friend she met the bare
minimum standard folks
of telling the truth and it and adhering
to the truth and making sure to defend
the truth that's a bare minimum standard
for someone who is in Congress number
one number two someone who is of a
family that is basically political
royalty for all intents and purposes
yeah it's a bare minimum standard we
should not be making her the [__]
hero of democracy Liz Cheney is no
goddamn picture perfect
example of what democracy looks like get
the [__] out of here but let me tell you
something if she's going to go after
Trump boy I'm gonna encourage it I'm
going to cheer her on you damn right
get your [__] ax out and chop him
down Liz Cheney let's do that
so I think CNN
um
made a great business decision here
um to have Trump on and Trump is he's
he's [__] truthing about that this
morning too
bragging about how he gets ratings
on CNN
and it's only because America loves
loves loves tragedy right like when
you're driving down the highway and
there's a huge car accident no matter
how gory or gruesome or crazy it is you
slow down and you're looking right
that's America in a nutshell it's crazy
speaking of tragedies
um holy moly we everyone was jumping to
conclusions calling the shooter at Allen
uh Neo now oh guess what he's a Neo-Nazi
he's a Neo-Nazi
of course he is why wouldn't he be
this isn't and I'll tell you that uh a
lot of folks on the internet
um are getting uh all twisted up about
this person who is of Hispanic descent
being a Neo-Nazi look we you do not have
to go very far back
into into Nazi Germany's history to
understand that there were that there
were Jewish Nazis there were it doesn't
it you're not understanding ideology
right you're not understanding ideology
ideology sometimes rips through cultural
barriers barriers of race barriers of
gender sex
and he I mean Jesus Christ the majority
of trump supporters in this country vote
against their self-interest vote against
their self-interest in in support of
affiliation because Trump and pro-life
and white supremacy you don't you don't
think that it's way far veg that someone
who is a Hispanic dissent would would
believe and adopt white supremacy and
Neo-Nazi ideas come on this is
ridiculous you don't again this country
does not understand ideology I get this
[__] all the time I've seen I've seen
something the other day a meme that said
oh the Democratic party is the party of
the KKK and the party of the Confederacy
so why does if the Democratic party is
the picture of the Confederacy and we're
the we're the heritage of the
Confederacy in the KKK today's
Democratic party is the Heritage then
why are you so [__] hell-bent on
keeping your [__] Confederate flag at
your Democratic Heritage so you're
flying to flag of democratic Heritage on
the back of your [__] pickup truck
putting it in your window of your house
putting it on a sticker on your [__]
old broke down Camaro really that's
that's your Democratic Heritage that
you're supporting it seems to be that
you're saying two things at once and
people in this country just do not
understand ideology they don't get it
they don't understand it and I'm sorry
Americans I and I'm gonna say it out
loud and people might get mad Americans
are [__] dumb they're dumb as dog
[__] and they just don't understand
ideology they don't get it
they don't get it and that is why we're
at risk here this is why this is why
fascism is leaking into our [__] into
our [__] politics into our [__]
state legislators into the House of
Representatives
why do you think this [__] is is is
[__] the number one threat is because
we clearly as as a body country as a
collective of people in our borders do
not understand ideology we don't know
what it is we don't understand it's not
about parties ideology is not about
parties parties are [__] are
different that's a that's a power
structure to govern and to set policy
dummies it's not ideology that is not it
and until we [__] uncouple our brains
from what ideology actually is and what
we have some stupid
false idea of what it could be or should
be or can be like Democrats versus
Republicans that's not ideology it's
always been Democrats versus Republicans
dummies that's a two-party system what
the [__] what the where the [__] have
you been
ideology breaks all those barriers it
can and it will
that's why we must have a certain
narrative we must speak out
about this ideology because it's not
just this ideology this this bigoted
[__] ideology again can move across
parties in a short period of time it can
take over certain organizations
I mean Jesus Christ especially a country
that's built on the institution of white
supremacy you don't think that these
things can flourish here you don't think
these ideologies will take hold
people are getting killed over this [__]
eight people at the Allen Texas mall
murdered three I think it's three kids
were [__] slaughtered a little
six-year-old boy lost his brother and
both his parents [__] gonna
grow up and live the rest of his life
knowing knowing that it was a gun A gun
that took his life away from took his
teenage year memories away from him took
the ability for his parents to be there
when he graduates you don't think that
[__] is gonna think about that
and you think it's Republican Democrat
get the [__] out of here
I've been telling you and yelling and
screaming that it's guns it's the guns
it's the guns it's the guns
and it's being perpetuated by white
gun culture and ideology folks
and people get mad when I say white gun
culture instead of gun culture but it is
prove me wrong
show me show me in this country any any
other
any other demographic other than [__]
rule white people that have a huge gun
culture show it to me show it to me and
show me where that isn't instituted and
the entire [__] country across the
country where they Institute it in
policy and law and state governments and
local governments and counties [__] you
you can go [__] yourself it's white gun
culture it's that ideology that we can
do whatever we want to do whenever the
[__] we want to do it and ain't no one
gonna stop us
it's that and let me tell you something
if you got a problem a gun will solve
your problem that's the ideology
it's a sickness it's a [__] disease I
mean we've seen it all over Christmas
cards when these lawmakers white
lawmakers
[__] boneheads are standing in front
of Christmas trees and holding their
[__] semi-automatic Rivals and [__]
as if that's what Jesus would do stand
in front of a Christmas tree which is a
pagan which is part of pagan belief not
Christian belief and holding their
[__]
rifles that are designed to kill other
humans I am oh there's definitely what
Jesus would do Jesus would totally yep
that's what get the [__] out of here
so it's not it's not that ridiculous or
surprising
that someone of Hispanic descent or any
dissent for that matter I don't care
what your background is to buy into
and to act on with with the ability of
Greg Abbott when he allows anyone and
everyone to get a gun apparently this
this person was discharged from the
military
there should have been red flags all
over this [__]
not only that the son of a [__] was
posting on a Russian social media
platform where he was posting pictures
of this small pictures of his guns
pictures of his ammo pictures of his
Nazi Nazi tattoos
the [__] out of here man
we
our culture
our ideologies made this made this
happen
and by voting Republican and having
Republicans in power it only allowed him
to kill eight people at that mall
we didn't stop him Greg Abbott in fact
he encouraged him
Greg Abbott sent out a treat tweet
months ago said I can't believe this
[__] California gun sales up more than
Texas come on Texas buy more guns
only encouraging more people to buy guns
although all the wild passing laws to
where there's no checks no one gives a
[__] doesn't matter when or why or how
you were discharged from the military
they don't give a [__] you're in Texas
get you again
[__] it go up and scope out malls if you
want to
hell why not hell why not we don't get
we don't give a [__] down in Texas
I know Texans do I'm sure [__] Texans
are sick and tired of this [__] and the
reason why is because yesterday I
believe it was yesterday there was two
Republicans that crossed the [__]
line they crossed the line and they
voted with Democrats in committee now
it's not who I I don't think this bill's
going to go anywhere but folks it's a
sign in Texas that people are [__]
listening when we are saying enough is
enough of this [__] you [__]
you got blood on your goddamn hands this
is you you are setting policy to make
sure these people can just kill whoever
they want whenever they want with
whatever they want without a background
check without anything nothing nothing
just hand them over the [__] guns and
let them kill people
and and they're starting to see they're
starting to see that this is not going
to be sustainable no amount of [__]
money from the NRA or the gun lobby or
gut or the handful of families that own
gun manufacturers in this country is
gonna do it
it's just not going to fend off the wave
of the country saying no that we're not
going to do that [__] no more
especially when we when we see this
confusing situation where we have
someone of Hispanic descent who is a
white supremacist a Neo-Nazi
going and killing people mainly Hispanic
people at a mall in Texas
because of Internet rhetoric
because of propaganda that somehow
Hispanic people coming across the border
rather their documented workers
undocumented workers refugees who gives
a [__] man who gives a [__] we should
welcome those people with love and open
arms
[__] out of here with this nonsense
I'm sick and tired of America saying
they're the best place on earth when we
clearly don't even believe in ourselves
we clearly don't as a collective we do
not believe that this is the best place
on Earth maybe we once did I don't know
I mean we can we can make it a Freer
country
we just we we have to stop electing
people who are going to oppress people's
rights
that's no Pathway to [__] Liberty
that's no Pathway to Freedom that's no
Pathway to the greatest country on Earth
it's just not
Equity equality and diversity is the
things we should be embracing
and we shouldn't be embracing these
people coming across the border
coming here with nothing
with with no with no real Outlook
just only that it's America that's it
that's it
that's that's the that's the reason why
and then we see in Brownsville Texas
this piece of [__] I guess he's been
charged with manslaughter they still
can't figure out if this guy
intentionally did it well he did
apparently he was
had an alcohol problem I don't know
plowed through a red light killing
trying to kill dozens killed nine people
I believe with his with his SUV
people just sitting waiting for a bus in
front of a migrant station
it's enough of this nonsense
dehumanizing people they're humans you
[__] they're humans stop
that's the reason why this [__]
[__] bought the Neo-Nazi [__]
and I I I I I I hope that title 42
expires and I hope I hope people who
will come here and make this country
better pour across the border [__] em
[__] em
you you would never in our country's
history ever seen a migration to our
country
that didn't end in a better economy that
didn't end in a better country a more
diverse cultural society
what the [__] is wrong with that and
what the [__] is wrong with us
pluck your head out of your ass it's
2023 [__] it's 2023 and there's
plenty of room for anyone in this
country
and if and if there isn't room we'll
[__] make room
stop your bullshitting stop bullshitting
yourself
that somehow you're more American than
anyone else who comes here your
experience is just as different than
anyone else your experience isn't
uniquely American [__] out of here
foreign we're all Americans that's the
beauty of America
and so long as you're here no matter why
you're here whether you were born here
rather your ancestors came here
rather rather your ancestors were
brought here as slaves
rather you come here as a in the great
migration in the late 19th century
are in the last hundred years
are in the last two goddamn days
Crossing that border
you're American
what the [__] else does it mean
it's time in this country that we stop
bullshitting ourselves about ideology
and I'm telling you this is the reason
why people are [__] confused and it's
and it's a weird [__] conversation it
shouldn't be a weird conversation to
have folks there are plenty plenty and
I'm
we've talked about it on this show with
Gabe Sanchez yes it doesn't make any
sense but there's plenty of Hispanic
people out there
that will believe stuff that is not in
their interest
it happens it's ideology
Q Anon is a great example they've been
able to use Q Anon a lot of a lot of the
Hispanic population is very religious
and superstitious and these things leak
into these cultures
it's okay though we're here for them
we're all together in this
we gotta stop bullshitting ourselves
that somehow this person can't be this
because of this or because of this [__]
that [__]
we watched as Kanye West
last six months satin said I love Hitler
what the [__] are you kidding me
you don't you don't think in a Nazi
Germany Kanye West would not have
survived very goddamn long
but there he is saying that sort of [__]
it's hard to make sense of it folks
because we can't stick it in the Box we
want to have it in
but it doesn't have to fit
it doesn't have to
but we have to have these conversations
we have to not stop yelling and
screaming for what is right and what is
right is to make sure these these
[__] people don't just get whatever
gun they want whenever they can it's the
[__] guns
and a prime example is Allen Texas
where it could have been stopped it
should have been stopped
and that little six-year-old boy would
not grow up
wondering why he lost his family in
front of an h m
he's gonna be told the story
over and over and over he won't
understand it much now as he gets older
he'll understand it unless then he'll
understand it more it'll be more
confusing
all because Greg Abbott wanted a bunch
of gun sales all because he wanted more
gun sales than California
that's why that that's why that little
boy is gonna grow up without a family
without his brother
really Greg Abbott that that oh man boy
that is the exact price we should pay
for Freedom right there baby oh man
that's a I mean you know it's not that
high of a price really you know I'm
[__] with human beings [__] with
their minds [__] with communities and
not that I pray for pay right
it's perfect price to pay for freedom
we have to keep speaking out
and yes it'll be little gains here and
there like in Texas in the committee
when two Republicans crossed over and
voted
to raise the age
of getting a gun
one little bitty step
and yeah it's going to take a lot of
little bitty steps but we are going to
do it and we're all going to do together
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
don't forget to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube right now
hit the Subscribe button also go follow
us on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google if you're still on
Facebook or you got a Facebook account
go over there at the Tony Michaels you
can follow us at the Tony Michaels also
if you want to support this is a really
cool thing and you guys you guys have
shown us so much Support over on Twitch
I can't believe it you guys are the best
in the world you really are and you keep
us going here every single weekday
but over on Twitch you guys have shown
us so much support and if you have an
Amazon Prime account listen if you have
an Amazon Prime account what you can do
is you can give us monetary support on
the show and it doesn't cost you a
single nickel more
and the reason why is because Amazon
gives you one free twitch subscription
with your Amazon Prime account it's five
bucks is what prime gives you they give
you one free subscription over on Twitch
so if you download the Twitch app and
download your Prime app
you can link the two your Prime account
to your Twitch account give us that one
free subscription off your Prime account
and we get a couple dollars here on the
show and boy let me tell you too those
people who don't have Prime accounts
you've been coming over and following us
because it's free to follow us on Twitch
so if you want to follow us on Twitch
and really you probably should because
every once in a while I get kicked off
YouTube
[Laughter]
everyone's a while get kicked off
YouTube and you might have to go over to
Twitch to watch the show for a week or
two uh so you might want to go follow on
Twitch so it's not that hard to find if
you if if you want to watch it over
there and the chats over the chat over
there is great we have Robin moderating
on the chat speaking a chance the up
wires YouTube channel Jim Williams is
our new moderator over there thanks
again Jim second day at the job all the
moderators are giving you tons of
Applause
for yesterday thank you very much on the
up bars to go to the upwire.com you can
follow the up bars Channel we broadcast
from there as well so follow us in all
the places that way if you know
I get banned for saying some [__]
then you can still watch the show the
show is always free free 99 five finger
discount don't go anywhere we got Texas
Paul when we come back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around to the break at
Texas all of this it's Tuesday Tuesday
May 9th
you know what Tuesday means
talk about tacos every once in a while
and we talk about Texas cold Texas Paul
oh thanks for joining the show my friend
is always on Tuesday
um big news this over the weekend in
Texas and um I know you'll probably have
uh plenty to uh to say about it today
I'm uh although I I will say it is kind
of weird to watch people being confused
about ideology
um in in the you know I talked about in
the in the beginning because a lot of
people don't they just don't get the
difference between like a two-party
system and what the the
[Music]
um differences between that of a party
platform and policy the politicians or
you know the different ideologies that
live inside those parties they just
don't clearly get what ideology is
you're muted by the way
yeah I tell you brother I you know just
a perfect example is you know I I'm in
tight with the unions I love the unions
I really do one of the things that that
unions are facing is you've got an old
white guy demographic right and
that ideology the the let's just flat
out call it what it is the racism the
you know that they grew up with that
they've been steeped in is there it
really is there these are people that
reliably vote Democrat these are people
that vote for there and Trish but
you know they're susceptible to these
ideologies there's especially and you
know this Tony this isn't just homegrown
astral you know homegrown uh you know
naturally occurring racism this is we've
got very well-funded groups that know
how to scratch the right spot on people
and they are pushing this racism and
ideology hard on that demographic
because they're susceptible to it
because they grew up with it they do
already have a bias you know and and
these are reliable Democratic voters
that we are having to put the effort in
to keep
right because ideology crosses party
lines right well and and it and it
transcends
um time and space sometimes too you know
I again I went to the argument and you
probably get this [__] a lot too oh well
the Democratic party is the party of the
KKK well I mean yeah but it's the
ideology that created the KKK not the
not the party they just happen to be in
that on that side of the aisle at the
time but most people don't they just
don't get the they don't even understand
the difference between liberal or
radical and conservative like you're not
even understanding these things these
simple ideologies between liberalism and
conservatism those aren't parties
liberalism and conservatism are not
parties those are ideologies and and
generally they're either economic or
societal ideologies they're not
necessarily uh steeped in race or or
culture right there's so many different
ideologies and people can have different
ideologies all at the same time right
this and this gets real confusing when
you have like um when you see an
interview like at the Trump rally
and they're like yeah I don't I don't
want to go broke because of Health Care
like yeah so that makes you liberal I'm
like no no I'm not liberal I'm a
conservative but I want that pen only
and I believe there should be no
abortions like you can have different
ideologies all at once even if you don't
even realize it right so
let's go back to this Allen shooter and
the reason why I want to focus on it in
this light is because so many people are
confused by this that uh someone of
Hispanic descent
can have an ideology that would drive
them to drive to a mall in Allen Texas
which I want you to speak on because you
know Alan Texas and to shoot mainly
Hispanic people at this mall in front of
an h m i mean why are people confused
about how this can happen
I have no idea why people are confused
as to how this can I guess it's people
that haven't grown up around Hispanics
that don't know that there's a large
segment of the Hispanic population that
considers themselves White
they just do
they it there's a lot of especially
folks that have been in the country for
Generations
um they are white they're you know this
shooter was not
100 percent Mexican he wasn't he was of
mixed blood so he considered himself
white even though his surname is
Hispanic his skin tone is a little
darker than mine
he still
latched on to that ideology and that
ideology you know and and like I was
talking a minute ago with the unions the
the tightrope you and I walk
is we have to defeat this ideology in
these groups
and understand how it works and how it
pervades and and and leeches into these
groups
without you know
we're not [__] racist Tony we don't
Pander to that [__]
so we have to get in these people's
minds and defeat the racism
and the other side just needs to infect
them just needs to Pander to the worst
instincts why I mean because that's the
easiest thing isn't it like just to poke
the stick at the Bear right that's the
easiest thing is to get the bear to wake
up and cause all kinds of chaos is just
to piss the bear off and what they do is
they they they go for their fears and
the easiest fears and the easiest fears
is
of culture race religion and it's in and
it's that culture war that the right
wants to wage because they know that
awakes the Sleeping Bear and causes him
to knock over everything right to cause
complete chaos and that's really because
that's where fascism really operates and
thrives is during a period of chaos
because fascism wants to build things in
its own image liberalism is like well we
got this thing and we think we can make
it better so let's just keep making it
better till we got what we want right
like that's the idea of freedom and
opportunity and Liberty that's not the
idea of of a far-right fascist ideology
a far-right fascist ideology wants to
tear the whole thing down to the ground
and then build it back up as a as a
fascist State that's what Ron DeSantis
is trying to do in Florida that's why
he's trying to destroy things he's not
trying to make things better he's trying
to destroy them to level them so that
way he can build them back the way that
that the fascists want right well you're
right about it you're right about that
Tony yeah and that's ideology right
that's ideology that's not parties right
parties are just where the power lies
for each election and how they get on
ballots and how we and how we we divide
up legislators and and different
executive branches throughout the
country and different governments
throughout the country that has nothing
to do with ideology I mean it can it
absolutely can but it has it they're not
mutually exclusive if that makes sense
yeah and that's one of the hardest
things that that we face you know when
we sit here in front of these
microphones and we talk you know we're
talking about what what are we selling
we're selling liberalism we're selling a
Multicultural Society we're selling
chaos to be honest with you right we are
we're selling chaos we're selling a
bunch of different people living a whole
different bunch of different ways
everybody's great and we all do better
when we all do better
they're selling that uniformed duck walk
Goose Steppin everybody's wearing the
same uniform we all have the same crazy
radical ass extremist uh uh Evangelical
ideologies even though we don't actually
conform to any of it but we're all going
to espouse the same things and we're all
going to wear the same uniforms and
we're all gonna you know
that's appealing to weak people
it's very appealing it's comforting to
weak people well yeah because you don't
have to make a lot of decisions right
yeah and you you don't have to
understand other people
you know you don't have to just say oh
well you know so you know it's hilarious
I give you a perfect example Tony uh you
know you know my wife she just she's got
a great sense of humor man she does and
she's watching you I mean she'd have to
right I mean come on no [__] right
there was a live on Tick Tock they had
set up a red carpet coming out of a
Subway
uh I assume it was New York I didn't
really pay close attention a red carpet
coming out and they had a dress-up day
right there in the middle of town just
spontaneous and it was hilarious man it
was lit and yeah you had some people
walking around with their ass cheeks
hanging out and you had people that were
dressing you know what I mean but the
whole thing was just fun
you know but that's really scary to your
average Midwestern went to church every
Sunday even though they've never read
the freaking Bible
um
you know the people I'm talking I know
you live with them in Missouri oh I know
you're talking about they would see that
oh my God look at that yeah not the
children you know hey in New York right
yeah
and it's It's A Hard Sell it really is I
mean we have to work very hard to keep
this liberal democracy in society that
we have
you know it takes work man it takes work
it does and I think I think messaging is
key and I want I want to get Gabe
Sanchez and I'm trying to force him to
get on the air here uh because I want
him get him in on this conversation
about the uh Allen shooter
um because maybe he could give more
insight I know Gabe's talking about
Nazis well we've been talking we talked
on this before
um about and it was really close uh
towards the 22 midterms about how
Hispanics are would would vote a certain
way that you would never think that they
would they they start believing things
that they don't and a lot of and there's
a lot of confusion right now on the
internet I was speaking to him at verse
30 minutes me and Paul were kind of
discussing it here it's a confusion that
of what ideology is and that this person
of Hispanic dissent bought Neo-Nazi and
white supremacy ideology right and
somehow people are like well how can you
you can't you can't be and he maybe can
wow he's got the swastika tattooed and
it's just it's people forget about
we're going to talk about him today
um yeah and because of this guy this guy
wasn't a watcher of Nick Fuentes Tim
Poole some other in-cell influencers is
if you want to call him that
um
yeah no I was gonna say I mean you don't
go into a tattoo shop and say hey let me
get those uh well actually it's not like
you could just go pick it off the wall I
mean who knows maybe in that there might
be a tattoo shop there might be it's
like here's a tattoo not to get and
they're like I want that tattoo or you
know most likely is this [__]
um Nazi went in and said hey I like
those things that uh are very bad and
then the guy you know I'm sure for a
certain price they're willing to do it
uh there also might be you know Nazi
sympathizer tattoo artists that are
willing to do it as well uh not like
those those uh
those symbols are very hard I mean
you're talking an S right angle s angle
why I never tattooed someone so I
wouldn't right right but I mean like if
you if you also think about it right
like
it's the most basic of tattoos it
doesn't take a lot of creativity to do
it and it doesn't take a lot of
precision to do it it's not like hey I'm
gonna go in and get a like this very
very fine-tuned shading or like get an
artist to do something that's very well
tuned so what you're saying is it's not
an accident it's not an accident it's
not an accident
and end up looking like Hitler that's
not what happened I mean you consider
how much Black Ink went into making
those tattoos that's a lot of [__]
that's a that that
it that would be a long session if not
two sessions to do those tattoos
that's that's reshading and oh yeah
because like you know for anyone who
like I've got tattoos on on my arms
right and like you know you start with
the outline and then you fill in but the
way that your body reacts is like any
abrasion it's gonna raise up so it's
getting probably one of those things
where he went in for two or maybe three
sessions because of how quickly your
your skin kind of bubbles up to a needle
scratching Across the Skin right but in
terms of like
um you know the Latino Or Hispanic
population
if ending up in this uh Pro
uh profasious Nazi white supremacist
movement like it's
it's not surprise I mean like you can
indoctrinate anyone right anyone of any
color of any Creed of any religion can
be easily indoctrinated and brainwashed
depending on what they have in their
surrounding area right depending on what
sites they frequent what videos they
watch what games they play whatever it
might be
I mean
you have to remember that uh the way
like for me personally it's always I'm
always dumbfounded right I'm always
dumbfounded a house someone who comes
from the Latino Community can do that
right and in ways I can't understand
right you've got a group that comes to
the US or wants to be a part of the U.S
and wants to be American and they feel
like the only way to assimilate is to
adopt those same cultures those same
beliefs right you already are an
outsider in your in your area right even
for even for children who have been born
first generation students in this
country feel like Outsiders like myself
right like when I was in high school
there was a mo there were moments when I
didn't I wasn't white enough or I wasn't
you know Mexican enough or whatever it
was and you know on both sides of the
groups you feel this tug like you know
tug of war where uh someone doesn't
accept you and then the other girl
doesn't accept you and so you kind of
feel like this you know you're in the
middle
and you know I think it's funny you
mentioned that because this shooter in
Alan Texans actually posted this on a
social media site I think it's called
okay it's like a Russian social media
site yeah yeah and I'm only showing you
part of it here and um and and it kind
of goes to what you're saying right
um and the reason why is because there's
a cross in the road and it says now this
is racist as [__] but it says Jack Black
or become a white supremacist right the
one is oh it's all sunshine and rainbows
over here the other one that's dark and
and become a white supremacist now who
is crossing this this Crossroads latino
children
um so this guy posted this this shooter
posted this on his social media
um and it maybe it speaks to what his
mindset was maybe it doesn't maybe he
just thought it was funny I mean but it
really does seem to be because he chose
white supremacy that he felt like that
maybe this he agreed with this that
maybe yeah I'm
sure this is you know you know is a meme
that goes for any type of uh
that anyone can use this in terms of
like how they want to split the road
right you're at a fork on the road you
take this path or that path and it could
be whoever is whoever is exactly right
and so when I look at this I'm like it
it's unfortunate because you know to him
he goes oh the only way
to have a good life is to act black but
then
you know I it's it there the undertones
of saying that oh you have to act black
which I'm sure it's like oh act black
act you know like I gotta be this like I
gotta be a you know probably if I had to
assume probably the lowest level of of
of how Society views different
communities right and for the black
community I'm like oh well if you act
this way a gangbanger do something this
or don't act you know how you proper in
society like then you're gonna be
accepted and that's you know that's how
you want to be but if you decide to
uphold these white ideologies then you
are going to be uh the the monster the
creature the thing that people don't
like right and
it hurts to see those kinds of things
like you sent me this and I was like
[__] this guy man
like [__] this kind of [__] where you
have someone from my own community
that goes oh well you know what here we
go I'm gonna [__] on the black community
while simultaneously [__] on the
Latino Community while also propping up
the white Community right and showing
and you saw this all yesterday too this
anti uh or this this
trying to push this pro-white bias right
or or rather trying to push this
anti-white bias in the media
misinformation elon's been pushing it
the whole [__] time the whole time
ever since the shooting started you've
got [__] miles Ian Chong and the
red-headed [__] libertarian and all
these other people you mean you mean the
turbo fim yeah the turbofem yeah
yeah I mean yeah it's always it's always
these Alpha cooks that are the ones who
are like oh isn't it so weird this looks
like a red flag and it's like no it's
not a red flag it is what it is it's
true to what happened and you're trying
to find a way to excuse the white
supremacy and the fact that you've got
Margaret Taylor green go it's a leftist
the shooter was a leftist I beg to
differ I don't think a leftist would put
this much [__] ink you can even see
this is like a fresh tattoo yeah they
actually just raised up and the the
Swansea now Texas Paul I want you to
speak to this because um I I don't think
a lot of people were commenting on this
where he has the Texas and the Texas on
his shoulder right and then he's got a
Dallas tattoo on his hand right yeah
that was one that was one of the things
that Marjorie Taylor green she called it
she's a [__] bull or some [__] on the
one on his hand but he obviously he
obviously had some pride in Texas right
like like he's from there he had Pride
there but all of a sudden the the white
supremacy culture of Texas seemed to
seep into this guy tell me what you
think about it nowhere else like nowhere
else in this country Tony
people born and raised in Texas are
proud of being from Texas there's a
reason there's all the secession talk
because we actually believe we are a
separate group of people we really do we
see ourselves as a nationality so it is
not weird to see Texas tattoos it is not
weird to see like he had a Dallas tattoo
on it that's not a gang tattoo folks
that is somebody the DFW metroplex they
are very proud of being from DFW I'm
telling you I am not kidding you I I
once made a comment that the that the
area between Dallas and Fort Worth was
the butt crack of the Metroplex good
Lord the hate I got on that
well but doesn't but doesn't his tattoos
here uh just signify what what we were
talking about earlier Paul that a lot of
things can be true all at the same time
that's why ideology is so complicated
but because it's complicated it makes it
easy to see this guy obviously is proud
to be from Texas right now Texas if if
you want to go a little further Texas
wasn't Texas Texas was Mexico I mean
Texas was Mexico at one point so I mean
and it gets all confusing and it gets
all
combatulated into our minds if that's a
word combatulated uh it's probably not
but here's the thing is I saw some
people saying
um oh man I was wrong this guy isn't
isn't uh whites or he he is a white
supremacist and I was wrong he's not a
he's not of the left here in America
he's of the left in Ukraine I saw a lot
of that [__] like he's Ukrainian now
he's under Ukrainian ideologies there's
Nazis in Ukraine I mean they can't stop
stacking the misinformation and the lies
and that's why the ideology can't keep
up right that's why I can't keep up well
that's how it works Tony I mean you
don't have happy well-adjusted people
that are that are following these
ideologies you're just not they are
designed specifically over they have
honed this over centuries
to to Target a somebody like this
shooter who is he was kicked out of the
army for being mentally unwell he is
obviously not happy in his life things
have not gone great for him he's in his
mid-30s working as a security guard this
is their perfect Target and that whole
ideology of either act or go white
supremacist really got into his head
because they really they'll find
whatever it is your your little sore is
and they will pick at it you know he he
did not feel comfortable or happy as a
Latino he didn't he did not I want to
make a correction here it is apparently
discombobulated what did you say I don't
know I don't know I said something
different I mean hillbilly what do you
want me to do that's my hillbilly
ideology I guess I don't know
so what what they do is they take a guy
like that and they give him somebody to
hate in his in this guy you could tell
they gave him black folks your life is
bad because of those people over there
and they have all kinds of straw man
[__] red hair it's really easy for
it's really easy for people to Institute
themselves into a white supremacy
institution when the tenement of that
white supremacy institution in this
country is to hold your foot on black
folks I mean that's that's that's the
entire system well also you have to
remember like within racism right you
have this
it's inherently built on class right
like not only is he talked about that
before right exactly like not only is
the color in in terms of where your
status is but also like even if you're
within a certain group of of white
people or Latino people or black people
right it's always going to be well I'm a
darker skin or a lighter skin uh or at
least I don't live on that side of the
day right I don't live in that
neighborhood I make more money so I'm
able to live on this side of the town as
you said right there's all these
different factors where somebody can and
it's an unfortunate byproduct of
capitalism right like people like oh
capitalism racist hey look you [__]
right it is the idea that you could say
that I'm better than you because of
these variables right I was more
successful than you in this Society
because of these things it's the idea
that
you're you know to Texas Paul it is a
scab right you're telling that person to
keep picking at it it never heals
because you keep finding something to
point out that's wrong oh God that's so
crusty oh I gotta scrape it off right oh
like this or that right you keep [__]
picking at it until I mean you're raw
and bleeding right and and it becomes
habitual there's almost like this
uh you know not Pavlov but like there is
this conditional formatting that's done
where you know the only way to get this
feeling this sensation to know that
you're better is to keep picking at this
thing which as a result is putting other
people down putting your foot on their
neck holding yourself higher than those
people because you're better than them
for whatever reason right and it's
unfortunate that we yeah yeah sorry
that's the message that's the exact
message that's how they got this guy
they said you are Hispanic and you work
you bust your ass and look you you
haven't enjoyed the fruits of the
country but look at those black people
over there man the country just hands
them everything I mean look at that I
mean they've got you know free trips to
college and I'm telling you I've heard
this [__] before firsthand people have
said this [__] to me they got free trips
to college they get freaking welfare for
everything that I mean there I went to
dinner with a cop that worked a little
town down over there close to where I
live and there is a uh well welfare
housing there is there's an apartment
complex and he's like man they're in
there for Generations man the grandma
was there the mom was there and now the
sun is there
and it's like dude
they do not have a good life there you
know what I mean they have taken nothing
from you but the message to him was
that they have right and about your
struggles all your struggles
the country was never there for you but
it was there for them
so hate them because you're one of us
you're one of the ones that work hard
and keep things going and that's why I
wonder you're better than him that's why
I wanted to bring this comment up from
Valerie she says self-hate and Paul's
right it's not self-hate it's get get
you to hate someone else so you love and
prop up another institution and prop up
their ideology again it's it's all in
the ideology and and that and that's
something that
and unfortunately Americans are just too
dumb to understand and and it's not that
they're dumb it's just we're ignorant
right Americans are I mean they don't
they aren't taught these things we
weren't educated on these things right
and that's the and I I that was actually
a point I'm glad you brought it up
that's the point I want to bring up like
when when Texas Paul brings up you know
low-income housing right in certain
areas
um it it's something that is built in
you know it's um
it's something that's built in but also
it is a constraint right there's no
education there's there's no knowledge
sharing there's no building up and
supporting each other right um because
we unfortunately say okay well this is
good enough for you this is what you're
gonna have and we're not gonna teach you
whatever you know whoever you might be
because it's not just black people that
live in live in low-income housing or or
low-income neighborhoods right
it could be of any race Creed or
religion these are people who just are
not of of good means and you know
Fortune at that time and when you have a
society again it really does come back
to capitalism in the way that we do not
educate and we do not share if I'm
successful right as a as a person of
society right what is the benefit if I
give someone else that knowledge and it
shouldn't be that way it should not be
that way at all we should be able to
share what we know sharing those
insights make sure that everyone is
successful to to their to their
potential right but if you continue to
hold people down and say you can't have
those things because you believe this
thing you look this way uh you're you
know your father your mother your
grandfather grandmother whoever it might
be they were here before you so this is
the position in which you will always
stay
we we are our country
is when you hear people that say those
things right they're like oh they're
just you know live there's welfare
queens and they're living off the system
it's like why do you think they're in
that position they don't want to be in
that [__] position but also Society
has taught them certain things about how
they're perceived right and it's taught
them that if they do certain things in
in act certain ways and this is the in
in many ways there's this like kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy right where
it's like well people don't respect me
to do anything good they just see me as
low less than so it's like why am I even
trying and that is a sad and unfortunate
thing that we have in this country where
we do not support others to be
successful and we hold them back so we
can prop ourselves up right I mean you
just kind of look at the way that people
run companies oh I'm not going to pay
you as much even though I know that the
value that put in this company is what
makes this company great I'm going to
lower your wages I'm going to Outsource
those jobs I'm not going to give you
bonuses I'm going to instead give myself
a bonus I'm gonna pay myself millions of
dollars I'm gonna give myself golden
parachutes on the way out right it's
everything to make sure that I can
spread this this income inequality so I
can keep you down and say you're
actually not worth it you're not
actually something I value even though I
use you and exploit you
but it's not me blame them exactly
exactly well and this meme was going
around radicalized by Nazis armed by
Republicans so that's the pivot I want
to make here because
um as dangerous as it is to have these
ideologies running around out in the
open because it used to be Texas Paul
that these ideologies kind of hid
underneath the rock right they're really
in covert in their operations now
they're overt in their operations and
the reason why we see it with with this
guy clearly because he was he was eating
up Nick Fuentes tempu uh podcast all
kinds of instances oh they did not like
they did not like that aspect
they were like oh no totally at last
time I just saw a tweets that were like
oh Tim pull was like oh great I'm
getting blamed for this now it's like
because on your page you [__] so
here's here's the thing though is that
ideology can be dangerous right it can
it can really
um cause a lot of violence violence in
this country and and not just our
country but anywhere ideology especially
when they start battling right I mean we
see this with Liz Cheney and Donald
Trump over this [__] ad and him
running for president again that that's
a that's a battle of ideology but it's
when we arm these [__] and
Republicans arm these [__] is
where it gets really dangerous and
deadly and where eight people lose their
lives in front of a [__] hmm and
Allen Texas not only not only because
Greg Abbott wants gun sales up in Texas
because that's the [__] truth you you
can you can knock on me all you want
Greg Abbott said I want gun sales up in
Texas and this guy [__] listen and
boy did he [__] and boy did he go use
those weapons of war just like they were
intended because not only did he go to
Allen Texas he didn't just randomly pick
that spot that [__] was staking
it out he was watching when the highest
uh times are gonna be he knew exactly
where he wanted to Target in that corner
if you look at that the overhead shots
of that [__] mall those people were
standing they were trapped in that
corner he knew they were going to be and
he knew he could kill them on the spot
and that was his goal that was his goal
to just as kill as many people as he
could at that mall in that particular
spot and and again the only reason why
this happened is because of Republicans
the reason why this tragedy happened not
because he was brainwashed into ideology
I mean you know people buy into
ideologies all the time good bad
indifferent the point is is that we
shouldn't be arming these [__]
we should not be arming people
especially [__] that were
discharged from the military Texas Paul
I know you have firearms and I know you
have a lot of experience with firearms
and you're a gun owner why why can't we
get it through our thick skulls that
just because someone has professional
training with weapons of war that
actually means that there should be more
back stops and more regulations on the
people who have formal training to use
these this Weaponry Am I Wrong to think
that
no you're really not and and I tell you
if we'd had red flag laws in place this
that would have actually stopped this it
really would have I mean this guy went
to basic he didn't finish basic he was
three months in he he
didn't finish
any of his Tech schools anything like
that and they said this guy's [__]
nuts he's got to go
and we did nothing from there
so we have a guy that's partially
trained yeah and we just turned him
loose on society that's insane that is
insane the fact that we're just arming
ourselves the way we are is insane I
don't know how the notion that freedom
is being
armed of the teeth
it's not it's just the opposite being
able to live your best life without
needing to be armed is freedom that's
freedom being able to tell Joe you know
Joe Biden these righties you know all
they want to do is cuss out Joe Biden
great you can do it without without
owning a single weapon because you have
freedom
they've worked in their minds that that
that the AR-15 is the symbol of Freedom
it isn't it is a symbol of fear and
oppression and again it's the white gun
culture that has has been just a disease
on this country's
um culture
that we can solve any problem any
problem you got you can solve it with a
gun and you see it in these shootings
where people are turning around in
someone's driveway knocking on the wrong
[__] door on the porch I mean who's
the guy last night who was like oh I saw
these they were playing hide and go seek
I think yeah he's like I saw some
Shadows bushes man shooting at children
in bushes because he sees Shadows again
this is that culture that says I have
the I have the privilege of solving any
problem I got with a gun because it's my
freedom the Second Amendment says so
which is just absolutely Bonkers so much
so that the FBI is putting out
Jesus Christ I can't even believe that
we're doing PSA videos on how to [__]
get away from a mass shooting literally
you remember the time in this country
when they were like this is your brain
and it was holding an egg this is a
brand you're brain on drugs and they're
frying the egg you know your brain tried
uh you know oh drugs dare just say no
that sort of [__] the FBI the government
is now it's not really funny but you
know what are you gonna do is putting
out PSAs on how to [__] hide how to
run and how to defend yourself if you
have to
in a [__] bar
if someone gets testy and brings out a
gun let's watch a bit of it
again this is the FBI put this video out
hi can I get you started with drinks oh
I'm sorry I gotta take this
we'll need them
back up you can't be here anymore
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
harder than him and then lose your
chances of survival don't go up here
[Music]
police where is he uh by the bar blue
jeans black shirt
empty hands up follow their instructions
okay so it goes on and on for about five
minutes right and it's and it's uh it's
supposed to be a video that's giving you
uh instruction or advice if you're in a
situation like this which
um most people in America are you are
going to be in a situation like this I
can guarantee empty it I don't care what
state you're in I don't care what town
you're in I don't care if you think
you're immune to this you're not you're
going to be in a situation like this
where there's going to be a fight
there's gonna someone's gonna get a gun
something's gonna happen rather shots
are fired or not or it can continues
you're gonna be in a situation where
you're gonna have to know what the [__]
to do and it's sad Texas Paul and Gabe
it's sad that you got to go to the
movies that you got to go to a concert
that you go in a restaurant you're
ordering food and you gotta [__]
scope out where the [__] exits are
where to [__] hide what do someone
comes in with a gun or two people get in
a [__] fight start throwing bullets
at each each other this is [__]
ridiculous that this is what it's
expected of us in public
polite Society it's [__] ridiculous
but it's Republicans who have done this
to us because I say it's not just the
it's not just the states like Texas that
have lacked gun laws because you can go
to Texas Get Your Gun drive back to
wherever the [__] go to this state that
state this is a result of policies that
that reward the blood that is on the few
families in this country that
manufacture these weapons award that is
what it is and that is why we are
spending our tax dollars trying to make
PSAs to make sure people get out of the
restaurant when someone starts opening
fire it's [__] ridiculous but I mean
we shouldn't here's the thing like you
know I
like we shouldn't have to live in fear
right I shouldn't have to
I shouldn't have to worry about if I can
go see you know
the [__]
like what movies out right now uh
yeah like I shouldn't have to worry to
go see that movie this week
because I fear that someone's gonna go
and shoot up the [__] movie theater
because of whatever right I shouldn't
have to sacrifice or we shouldn't have
to sacrifice innocent lives because
Republicans want to [__] their guns
right they have some [__] weird
fetish
where they think guns are higher in
terms of the food chain and priority
than other human lives right the
Christian so-called Christian values
right no none of that stuff I shouldn't
have to worry like you said I shouldn't
have to go in
to a public place and [__] assess
everybody and be like all right I got a
guy in my my nine o'clock my guy on my
two o'clock he's a little [__] like that
is something that you would see from
like someone who is trained in the
military who has to go through and
assess like any possible targets or
threats like I shouldn't have that game
Texas wants to Battlefield train
three-year-old our third graders for
Battlefield triage were crying out loud
so I mean why shouldn't we all be
trained in in Battlefield tactics right
uh when you go out to get a hamburger
you should be prepared to get shot down
and killed I mean this is and this is
folks I want to be clear on this PSA I'm
actually not excited about the PSA uh in
the fact that this perpetuates the white
gun culture it perpetuates the gun
culture that alls we can do is see where
the [__] exits are and how fast you
can run to them [__] that [__] that is
not the only thing we can do you need to
yell and scream and say we shouldn't
have these [__] PSAs we shouldn't be
teaching children in Texas Battlefield
triage you [__] we don't need
to raise fences up around [__]
playgrounds and and
razor wire around the school
they have one door in and all the doors
are locked get the [__] out of here
malls do not have to be prisons churches
don't have to be prisons this is not how
we have to live [__] that PSA that's
what I'm saying [__] that PSA we don't
have to live like that we don't have to
[__] take that as our message as our
message of what we can do to protect
ourselves what we can do to protect
ourselves is get rid of these
[__] who won't get rid of the
guns that's what we do you get rid of
the [__] who won't get rid of
the guns oh you won't vote against
[__] guns fine you're gone [__]
you're [__] gone you work for us
we're the [__] government you just
vote for us and if you won't vote the
way we [__] want you to vote and you
gotta [__] spend our money to make a
PSA to tell us how to [__] find and
exit and run as fast as you [__] can
because you [__] won't do your
[__] jobs [__] you that's what we
need to do that's the message we need to
send [__] your PSA just like your
thoughts and prayers you can stick them
up your [__] ass sorry I didn't know
that's fine I mean like
I get [__] pissed it's fine the other
thing I want to add to that is the fact
that like
we live in a society right now where the
expectation is that when a gunman comes
into a public setting it is now up to
those people the potential victims to
save the day we are now expecting I mean
like now we have this PSA from the FBI
which I don't like I mean again it's
cringy all around but also is telling me
that now I have to live in fear no
matter where I already have that
kind of situation in my head right right
I don't need more anxiety to be like
okay look for the exit yeah I already
know what the [__] do in the
situation run for my goddamn life am I
going to go try to stop the shooter you
better [__] not believe I'm gonna do
that [__] okay because here's the thing
I look out for number one look at my for
myself I look out for my partner that's
it those are the only things on my
[__] mind right now if a person comes
in with a [__] gun okay and I'm not
going to sacrifice my life for someone
else and there should not be the
expectation that anyone else should have
to do the same we should not have to
live in a society where if a gunman
comes into a public setting a church a
synagogue a grocery store a [__]
theater whatever it might be I should
not have to live in fear and then have
the expectation the pressure from
society and Republicans because they
won't lift a [__] finger to put in
legislation that I have to be the one to
save today I have to be the good guy
even without a gun right and we know
that even with the gun the good guys
don't do [__] we saw it in Uvalde we saw
it even at in the the Nashville school
at the Covenant right and the
Presbyterian school there were two
teachers on staff or two staff members
that roll in [__] gar they have guns
and they didn't do [__] right they had
to wait for the police to show up and
actually do it so we as a society should
not have to have the expectation the
pressure from everyone else to say well
if a gunman comes in you have to be the
solution this isn't [__] like you
know this is The Terminator
it's also not like only you can prevent
forest fires only you can stop a mass
shooter no that's where we're going
that's where we're going we're gonna
have a cartoon character that's going to
tell us well I'll tell you that you
should not have that
surprisingly that is not where we're
going Tony you don't think guys like me
you know I love my guns you know I do
right I love them online shooting yeah
I've grown up shooting I lost my hearing
to shoot competitive shooting I'm
telling you guys what's that you said
yeah
take them yeah
take them take every last one of them
it's not worth it if if me having those
guns means that [__] third graders
have to learn Battlefield triage and
[__] school take every last
[__] one of them and shove them
up your ass that's the way I feel about
it I have guns that belong to my father
I have guns that belong to my
grandfather take every last
[__] one of them if the choice
is I keep those or [__] kids learn
how to use a goddamn tourniquet
take every last [__] one of
them and I am not alone Tony I am not
there's been a sea change there really
has righties don't see it they're still
running their mouths they are they don't
see the change that's happening and I've
warned them over and over again if you
want to keep your guns be responsible
accept things like registration accept
things like red flag laws do responsible
things or you're going to lose them the
body count has gotten too high
and the reaction you know pendulum swing
and they swing far
because they have not participated
because they have not done the
responsible things
take them take them all from everybody
every last one of them melt them down
and make [__] steel out of them you
know make aluminum out of them throw the
[__] plastic away
just that's where everybody is Tony that
really is where the majority of people
they're just sick of this they're just
tired of it I think you're right I've
said it before that if the 2A Bros don't
get to the table and start
um
excuse the punt laying down their guns
laying down their arms and starting
having real conversations about how
they're going to keep their guns
um in some form or fashion this these
Generations that are coming up aren't
going to do it they're just not you've
tortured them you're gonna torture them
their entire childhood they're not going
to let their kids and their grandkids be
tortured and they're going I'm telling
you if you [__] the two a Bros
out there I'm speaking to you who think
that this thing is unaffringible and
there's nothing you can do and we can
have whatever guns we want whenever we
want and it's all right and God gave it
to us
you're in for world of hurt in in this
next 20 30 years when people there's
real movements to repeal the Second
Amendment I'm telling you it's coming
people are going to say it they're sick
and tired of your [__] they're gonna you
won't even you won't even do the polite
thing to make sure that the right people
who who have the ability to have guns
have guns
you're not even willing to talk about
that so I'm telling you they're gonna
move the [__] goal post on you and
you ain't gonna like it and this
country's gonna go with them because
Texas Paul is right people do not want
that stupid [__] PSA or when you're
ordering a goddamn hamburger you gotta
worry about the [__] exits for you
and your family it's [__] ridiculous
to think that you you should be
Battlefield trained to go out in public
grab a drink or have a meal with your
family or go to church or go grocery
shopping or go to h m and buy a pair of
[__] shoes
the people are not it's gonna stop one
way or the other so you choose to ABRA
because it's really it's the culture
because if the NRA membership and this
these [__] these [__] slugs out
there who think if you talk about gun
control then you're you're treasonous
you dumb sons of [__] I'm telling you
if you don't pluck your head out of your
ass and come to the negotiating table we
are going to shut you out of the
negotiating table you are not gonna get
a seat and at this point I'm saying
you're not [__] welcome at the node
go Shane table I don't want to hear from
your ass
if your ass can't even be reasonable
about what guns and who's got them then
you're then you're not even you're not
even welcome at the table to compromise
because your compromise isn't a
compromise it's not it means blood on
people's hands in this country and
that's not satisfactory it's just not I
agree with Texas Paul and I I I fear you
know the last thing I know they're going
to go on yeah something and I just want
to say like
it's it's the unfortunate reality that
the expectation I have on Republicans is
that if there was another shooting and
one of their family members were the
victims right whether shot or killed
whatever it might be
I unfortunately have the expectation and
I'm sure you guys too is the is that if
they were the victims and and you know
were killed by the hands of a mass
shooter
they wouldn't do anything
they would stop and say
it is what it is and we can't do
anything about it right it's like
[__] Birch it right [__]
representative bird [__] out of
Tennessee yeah right
now
you'd stick your daddy's and he's like
what do you do what do you do to keep
your your daughter safe oh we'll be
homeschooler oh well if only we had that
that ability that luxury because you
know you know exactly why because your
party has created a societal problem and
will not do anything yes representative
birdshit it's [__] Tim Tim burchett
out of Tennessee I think that's the
thing hedge ass here on uh on YouTube
representative bird [__] well we can't
they're all yeah yeah but here he isn't
close enough to bird [__] where I call
him representative you're Republican
you're a representative is this guy is
the is one of the problems right they
they see this and they say well there's
nothing we can do it is what it is c'est
la vie that's life and it's like no
[__] you actually have the
ability to do something about it right
it's not just thoughts and prayers it's
not just well speaking of thoughts and
prayers here's Ted Cruz's this is
what the messenger that he copies and
pays no no no this was debunked that it
was all him every time
what do you mean like this this somebody
made this graphic a while ago and
they'll look how many times this has
been like copy pasted by Ted Cruz it
turns out that it was just it's a it's a
a graphic that somebody made it was
debunked right but he he does post this
no no no no no no no no no no no no
what what I'm saying what it is is is is
is I'm I'm agreeing with what Gabe is
saying
this is out there and I was going to say
that this has been debunked as it's not
really Ted Cruz posting these
but it's identical to what he says yeah
yeah and everybody just accepts that
that that is just real yeah right
because what Gabe is saying is
absolutely true if Ted Cruz's ugly
[__] wife got shot
he would put out the same [__]
statement and keep on rolling
you didn't say that Trump said that
right his ugly wife you didn't say that
Trump said you know what if he won't
stand up to Trump he won't stand up to
me so [__] it she's ugly
laughs
hey what are you gonna do but what
you're right you're right you [__] they
won't stand up for their loved ones they
won't defend their family members and if
their family members were the victims of
a mass shooter they would stop shrug and
say well that's what God wanted that's
what happens it is what it is and they
wouldn't do anything and then they'd be
like oh man I'm gonna I'm gonna make
sure that people have access to more
guns and I'm gonna make sure that it's
written in an acronym that is the
spelling of my family member's name like
some dumb [__] like that I guarantee it
I guarantee they would do something they
would [__] put a poor memory of their
family member by making sure that more
people had guns well we're gonna [__]
arm the kids now we're gonna make sure
that in that tourniquet kit on the wall
that's you know needs a step ladder for
the kid to get up to there's gonna be a
[__] nine millimeter right there
right already loaded cocked ready to go
yeah that's where they're wanting to go
you know I've I've I've got the little
SpongeBob Band-Aids from my grandkids
I've got the little Paw Patrol Band-Aids
from my grandkids and right next to it
you know if the right Wingers get their
way there'll be little Paw Patrol
tourniquets
there'll be little SpongeBob tourniquets
well [__] we already got bulletproof
backpacks and bulletproof Library rooms
or whatever the hell it is and white
boards that turn out that's what it is
that's what it is I I was thinking it
was like bookshelves or some [__] but
it's whiteboard what do you mean they
took all the books away no one's going
wow right that's what I'm saying they're
going to use the bookshelves as
barricades not to use them for [__]
books in Florida
um speaking of Florida men I'm gonna
move on here and sorry I I don't mean
and that's a shitty transition but what
are you gonna do speaking of a Florida
man he's gonna be on CNN this a special
Florida man Texas Paul is going to be on
CNN for a town in New Hampshire [__]
man can you believe though hey actually
I'm I'm buying into this CNN thing
here's why you know who called him out
back in 2018 so when I was doing the
what was that for the correspondence
Center back in 2018 Michelle wolf was
like don't don't laugh it off man you
guys are addicted to Trump you guys have
to play his [__] and she called out
everyone she was like you guys you mean
CNN she was like you know you guys are
all dependent you created this thing you
you Amplified it and now you're
dependent on it so don't act like like
you you aren't all you're too good for
it you're [__] you're in there with
them you are the one who are [__]
bolstering him and she called him out I
mean it was a beautiful moment never
like oh and she's like no no don't don't
shrug it off you you're part of the
problem don't growl at me well here's
the funny part is he's going to New
Hampshire right it's going to be on CNN
and somebody back to New Hampshire right
well whatever so he's gone to New
Hampshire to do this down all on CNN
somebody
and CNN I don't know maybe this is the
Brilliance of it CNN just sold a huge ad
spot to somebody maybe maybe not named
Darth Vader Jr it's possible let's take
a look at this commercial that's going
to play during the town hall on CNN
Donald Trump is the only President in
American history who has refused to
guarantee the peaceful transfer of power
he lost the election and he knew it to
become the president he betrayed
millions of Americans by telling them
the election was stolen he ignored the
rulings of dozens of Courts rather than
accept his defeat he mobilized a mob to
come to Washington and March on the
capitol then he watched on television
while the mob attacked law enforcement
invaded the capital and hunted the vice
president
he refused for three hours to tell the
mob to leave there has never been a
greater dereliction of Duty by any
president Trump was warned repeatedly
that his plans for January 6 were
illegal he didn't care and today he
celebrates those who attacked our
Capital Donald Trump has proven he is
unfit for office Donald Trump is a risk
America can never take again the great
task is responsible for the content of
this advertisement yeah I got to give
CNN one thing on this yeah is they've
really pulled the curtain back
they don't give a [__] about the country
they don't give a [__] they have no
responsibility they are there for
[__] drama
they are there to sell ads that that is
it that is it they have lost also you
know back in the day when we grew up
Tony news there was responsibility news
was a lost leader because people were
responsible and people needed to be
informed as to what was going on
gone it's all gone it's all
entertainment you know at least CNN's
being honest
you know
you've got a guy that's an
insurrectionist you've got a guy that
tried to steal the presidency and create
fascism but hey [__] it we can sell some
ads
she refused says CNN is total trash
GOP light
um of course I mean someone's got to
pick up the slack for Fox News now that
they're potentially going to be out of
business you know I don't know but it's
one of those things
it's Fox uh CNN you know I mean
obviously because you know a lot of
people are like oh the new CEO of CNN is
very you know he's pro-right uh you know
it's it unfortunately goes to to what
Texas Paul is saying is where it's like
you have a person who's running the
network and you have
broadcasts that are done in support or
are lenient or our light or our uh easy
going on on the former president despite
the fact that we know that I mean like
he's dude he's you know we're waiting to
hear back from the jury on the Eugene
Carroll defamation lawsuit there's the
Georgia loss the investigation case
right now there's You Know Jack Smith on
Mar-A-Lago and also Jan six
um you know there there are all these
different things and CNN goes ah you
know what the guys had a hard rap I mean
we should give him a second chance maybe
he maybe he'll turn a new leaf and maybe
he'll give us all what we want and even
though that's not what they really
believe
because they know that Trump is uh you
know he's a traffic Pusher right he is
someone that if you mention his name
he's going to push traffic he's you know
whether you say [__] about him in terms
of being uh you know making fun of and
mocking him or you're in support of him
whatever it is the unfortunate reality
is the guy does get traffic and CNN sees
that as an opportunity to say well uh
you know profit over people right you
know money over over democracy and and
for us commentators it's not the same
right we can call it out we can we can
we can we can blast the [__] that
they're having but to be someone who has
a major News Network right that runs
nearly 24 hours a day right
internationally both in print online and
also on TV
you know it's funny that Liz says a
dereliction to duty because I look at
CNN and I say there is a dereliction of
Duty as a as a media Network to say hey
you know what we should we should give a
little screen time to the big guy you
know the guy who as if he didn't already
have enough right we should you know we
should give him we should give him the
ability to do a town hall dedicated to
him for an hour or two hours whatever it
might be and maybe maybe he'll win over
some voters why are we [__] doing
that other than the fact of what Texas
Paul said money money money money money
money money money money well let me let
me challenge let me let me push back a
bit because Texas Paul let me ask you
isn't there some good and for the entire
country to see what how much of a
lunatic this guy is because
we'll [__] destroy this guy for this
he is I mean we will [__] destroy him
but that's not the point the point Tony
you know who made the same exact mistake
who's that the Germans yeah the Germans
made the same exact mistake hither went
to [__] jail
and they had the chance to cancel that
guy and they didn't
they let him come out they let him keep
talking
and here we are history Is What It Is
Well speaking speaking of Hitler talking
Gabe can you I'm gonna pull up a uh one
of his posts today but can you get me
the link to his
fraud Social account because he's got a
bunch of them I'm sure he's been [__]
messaging on there since I we started
but here's the one this morning everyone
keeps uh circulating the one around
about the uh the verdict in the E Gene
Carroll trial but I think this one's
actually more significant Texas Paul uh
leading to his criminal legal woes here
um because he says Bill Barr was a
sloppy lethargic mess as the Attorney
General I don't know what that means
he's saying he's fat like an attorney
general can't be fat I mean he picked a
buy like I I just I also did I just
wanted people but then they're not the
best people I don't I just want to point
out that uh that you look at all the
people that were previously in his
administration right that he hand-picked
as he says I only have the best people
right the best the best people yeah
every one of those people even Kelly uh
even you know kellyanne Conway uh even
recently it was
um Kaylee mcinany he [__] on her because
she's supporting DeSantis right now so
it's funny to see him put all these
[__] on blast which is great
[__] eat each other I love it
whatever but it's funny to see this guy
who says I only hired the best and I'm
draining the swamp and then as soon as
they don't support him or they say
something that isn't too nice about him
he's like oh [__] you and then talks
about how shitty this person is it's
like well if this person was shitty
they've probably always been shitty that
means that you intentionally put someone
shitty on your staff or in his advisor
or an Administration so what does that
say about you right well I think I think
Bill bar is really shitty and Texas
Paulie goes on to say he says he was
lazy as hell petrified of the radical
left Democrats and the fact that they
were going to impeach him I wish they
had which would have meant that he was
doing his job which he wasn't which that
leads me to this point is why I think
because Bill Barr can you find the um
not only this but the clip of Bill Barr
disparaging him yeah
um in the last few days but he says this
specifically Texas Paul
bad on Election fraud and just about
everything else he touched sloppy bill
is now a human sound bite along with
Karl Rove wow wacky Peggy I hate Reagan
Noonan Paul Ryan for Rupert Murdoch and
his anti-trump just like 2016 Wall
Street Journal plus what I don't
understand a lot of this but I think
what he's getting at and I think what
he's scared of is the fact that bill
Barr is publicly speaking out against
he's a [__] dummy not only that he
did try to steal the election he tried
to steal it and Bill Barr's saying he
tried to steal it that's why I quit
because I don't want to go to federal
prison and he wasn't willing to go to
federal prison for Donald Trump I think
that's why Donald Trump's upset with him
what do you think
yeah I mean he was willing to to
suppress reports he was willing to to
rewrite reports he was willing to lie he
was willing to do anything and
everything right up to the edge
and then he wouldn't step off with with
Donald Trump because there was that shot
that this coup wasn't going to be
successful I guarantee you if the coup
had been successful Bill Barr would
still be there with him would be
carrying his water explaining exactly
Bill Barr is no [__] Patriot he is
not he is he is a worthless piece of
[__] and the scary part is folks and I
don't know how to explain to you it's
any simpler than this
Donald Trump keeps getting people around
him that are worse and worse and worse
and worse
the people that will do
yeah yeah his next Attorney General will
not give a [__] about the law okay let's
let's play pretend let's pretend like
the worst in the world happens and he
gets to pick an attorney general Gabe
Sanchez who do you think he picks what's
your guess who do you think it is oh
um
the worst thing you can think of worst
person I'm trying to think like who's a
reality uh Texas Paul what about you why
Gabe's thinking here 10 star Ken star
Ken Starr star will do anything Gary
Busey I I want that I was thinking Tom
Vinton yeah
he's not a lawyer uh speaking of shitty
lawyers here's uh play this after you
play this because I want to call Bill
Barr on the [__] after you play this
I want you to play another clip that I
just said that is it the one from Aaron
rupar down at the bottom yeah yeah okay
okay let's play this one this one is the
one that Trump is upset about what Trump
is upset that bill Barr wouldn't
overturn the election for him he's
really upset about that and and that
bill Barr wouldn't go to prison for him
I remember he laughed he laughed all
that [__] out right like during the Dan
chick's deposition he called it he
called the [__] 2 000 mules [__]
yeah no he called [__] would be
better if it was horseshit or mule [__]
you know what I mean I'm just saying in
the same wheelhouse let's listen to Bill
Barr disparage Donald Trump because this
is fantastic I I can't get over this
this is great
yeah yeah and this this man knows what
that we're coming up against the top of
the hour here too I am honored I'm
honored to be here in general who are
you really on my honored person
in the way he's got his shirt on at
least
all right all right all right enough of
them
more serious uh than maybe some of your
remarks but I I you are my favorite
person in Washington I think the most
honest person oh my God
given that okay he's made mistakes and
okay January 6th okay this and that it
is his policies that we'd be voting for
given the pragmatic side also do you
think he is emotionally fit to be
president of the United States I
disagree I think that Trump and Biden
will be the candidates uh that whatever
that says about the United States
is he fit to be president of the United
States finally a [__] question uh
what this is the way I'll answer that or
I'll go which is if you believe in his
policies he's the lat what what he's
advertising is his policies he's the
last person who could actually execute
he does not have the ability for
strategic thinking we're setting
priority oh keep going keep going or how
to get things done in the system yeah
there's no cameras no microphones keep
going when he's in when you know when
he's left
and and so you may want his policies but
Trump will not deliver Trump policies he
will deliver chaos and if anything lead
to a backlash that will set his policies
much further back than they otherwise
would be and that and that gave Sanchez
I don't know somehow in Texas Paul that
is why I want I want Donald Trump to be
the nominee no it's gonna I mean because
it is because of this we can run this
okay I mean everyone everyone on the
Republican side is making the ads for us
right all you have to do is you make a
montage you throw some clips in of stuff
you want to highlight you have a
voiceover I mean you look at [__] Liz
Cheney what she just did right she she
voiced over but just use [__] footage
from Jan six you play Jan six you play
build bar you play every one of these
people who [__] on Trump and distance
themselves because they're actually in
support of of DeSantis because they see
that as a path forward because he's not
currently under like [__] 10
different investigations at the same
time right they see a way out with
DeSantis even though putting fingers
high heels wearing the santis
isn't actually the path forward
but they need to distance themselves and
as soon as they do that as soon as they
put a line up and say
I don't want to be associated with Trump
at least publicly anymore right in terms
of a presidency run or candidacy uh
Trump shits on them right and boom that
bridge is burned right well yeah I'll
show that post I'll show this video I'll
show this interview I'll play that just
rack them up that's right whatever it is
when we get to the when the general
election we can pound them with their
own words and because because I I'm
gonna show this clip from from another
clip from Bill Barr I'm saying and it's
probably going to say almost the exact
opposite of what he was saying I think
it's what you're well this is the
problem that they all have especially uh
Paul Ryan right it's their inability to
say I won't vote for Trump right Trump
is a loser he's a loser we lost 2018
2020 2022 and if we're with them again
we're going to lose 2024. exactly
however they're like but with that being
said you know they're like but I'll vote
for the candidate what if Trump's the
candidate
um so Texas Paul what did you think of
Bill Barr absolutely axing up Trump In
that clip I I think he had some
technical difficulties there or
something yeah sorry about that I lost I
lost my connection there
um you know Bill Barr is just he is just
sorry I mean even if you go back to his
before he he actually worked with Trump
he's been a sleaze bag forever I mean he
this guy is a freaking wind sock man
wherever wherever the Republicans are
going is where his morals and characters
are the character is and it does not
matter man he he is useless and I want
my vote back I said Ken star I forgot he
died the audience caught that I
appreciate you guys I totally forgot the
guy died you don't think he would
nominate someone who's dead
I want to change my vote to Aaron to
Aaron Hawley Josh hawley's wife oh okay
do you remember when Trump didn't know
who Fred Frederick Douglass was and he's
like Frederick Douglas A lot of people
are saying a lot of good things about
hammers like he didn't know he died
well I mean at the time because they
were in a meeting right now but I'm
saying like you know I was like and then
my African-American like do you think
that's who he thought as
African-American maybe he maybe he
thought his name was it's possible his
name was Frederick maybe it was
clearance Thomas I don't know it could
have been I mean we know Harlan Hitler
says that right well here's here's
Harlan Hitler's friend I'm I bet Bill
Barr and Harlan Hitler have oh he's the
living embodiment of weaponizing the doj
he is a real scumbag he well yeah he's a
[__] scumbag look at this game but
let's listen to here how he's gonna say
different than what he said in the last
clip I commence
that's those are serious that's serious
that's a serious one I said that I I
personally think that they probably have
the basis for legitimately indicting the
president I don't know I'm speculating
but but given what's gone on I think
they probably have the evidence that
would check the box they had the case so
he's a criminal
should they
that's a decision for uh if you were AJ
would you
no because you protected yeah yeah of
course
I think it's becoming incredible did you
see that look on his face did you see
that look on his face when she asked
that question like
come on have you ever met me I mean
let me see if I can get this loaded
again God damn it okay here we go you
know that's an important
oh [__] wow you gotta be kidding me man
why really in the middle of the show
what the [__] going on I mean man
we're all in suspense I know I'm waiting
to hear him say the words man what what
are the words that he was gonna say
because it's not gonna play out here
I'll load it in I'll load it in
and [__]
and let me serious that's serious he's
gonna have to make that call here we go
God damn it every time I make it bigger
every time I make it bigger that's what
never mind uh
that's not what she said she went
so small that's for sure no not to me
not to me yeah [__]
[__] both of you all right all right let
me see I can control this show let me
see if I can load this in directly okay
um well see if you can get that one
loaded in while we're waiting on that
let me go to um let me go to Grandpa's
true social page and the reason why I
need to put somebody put Viagra in the
comments I'm sorry folks I'm old if
Viagra don't make it any bigger
oh you still only got the fishing pole
you came with
so yesterday yesterday text Paul we we
did a 20-minute bit on butt deodorant
and now today here we are talking about
boners all right I got the video loaded
in okay let me let me go to the
whoo let me go to the video
um let's see if we can get to that spot
documents
that's those are serious
that's serious that's a serious one I
said that I I personally think that they
probably have the basis for legitimately
indicting the president I don't know I'm
speculating but but given what's gone on
I think they probably have the evidence
that would check the box they have the
case and if they have it should they
that's a decision for uh if you were AG
would you
I'm not going to get into that do you
think they will
I think it's becoming increasingly more
likely and you think it would be
appropriate if they did well it's this
is what the Attorney General gets paid
these kinds of decisions you know the
argument for doing it is that if you let
someone like this who you know if the
facts are as raw as they may be and you
let someone get away with it uh how can
you protect these secrets how can you
insist on people in government taking
this stuff seriously
uh so you know that's an important thing
to weigh as well as what the you know
what it will do to the country and to
the office of the presidency and I think
uh Merrick Garland is going to have to
make that call
if Donald Trump for the nominee for the
Republican party again would you support
him
well I'm just hoping it never comes to
that because I think it would be a
tragedy if he's our nominee if he's the
Republican nominee
um could you vote against him could you
vote not for the Republican if Donald
Trump were the Republican again I think
it gets down to what I said which is I
would have to make the Judgment at that
point
or the impact on the country and I'll
have to see what's going on in the world
what who the Democratic nominee is if
it's a progressive Democratic nominee I
can't imagine voting but ideologically
Progressive versus somebody who
orchestrated an attack on the capitol
whom betrayed his oath to the
Constitution as you said in your words
you still might vote for him
depending
Maria of course I would why wouldn't I
why wouldn't I I [__] hate that guy
but why wouldn't I vote for him what the
[__] and again Paul Ryan's the same way
right the idea that they're asked the
question would you vote for Trump well
you know we can't back Trump because
he's a loser right we've lost all these
elections because of him
well it depends I mean I'll vote for the
Republican nominee but if he is the
Republican nominee and they're like well
I guess we'll just have to wait and see
we've talked about this multiple times
about this is what they did for the last
several decades they made the Democrats
an unacceptable option it doesn't matter
what the policy is that the policy
doesn't matter they they engaged in this
culture war that we did not engage in
they've got people like Bill Barr and
everybody else out there that's the one
that's the Rubicon they cannot cross is
they cannot ever say a Democratic
candidate is an acceptable candidate to
vote for because that is what they spent
all of their effort and money and and
and hundreds and you know billions of
dollars trying to create that narrative
within their bit within their party that
Democrats are unacceptable it doesn't
matter if this guy is a [__] criminal
that wants to Detroit our country he's
not a Democrat
well and you make a good point because
that really I mean gets to the heart of
where they are in their rhetoric
specifically Grandpa Poopypants he is
freaking the [__] out this morning I
mean freaking out on on fraud social now
normally we only show the ones that are
of news but I think it's newsworthy to
show how much he's freaking out this
morning this was him waking up Gabe
Sanchez this is his wake up message
Good morning Vietnam you remember that
movie he he wakes up in all caps he says
election interference at a level never
seen before in our country you mean like
going to Georgia and trying to [__]
bang up fake electors or Michigan or
Arizona you mean like pressuring the
Speaker of the House in Arizona to
overturn they like get the [__] out of
here he says we'll win anyways make
America great again again again and
again and again and again I I added that
last part but I think that would be
appropriate if he would I'm sure he'll
add as many again as he can well here's
a here's a true sponsor that look oh man
holsters holsters for guns they were on
jury social what do you know I'm looking
at I'm looking at them right now there's
another one I have which is like how to
make belly fat go away and then there's
another one which was around it was it
was a gun and it was bulletproof vest oh
well okay well you know really working
to Target to arm themselves for the mass
shooting they'll come in right so here
is
um damn here's him uh attacking Rhonda
sanctimonious as he calls in this
morning once people learned or start
excuse me started learning about Rhonda
sanctimonious he says his poll numbers
and popularity started to disintegrate
at a level and the speed rarely seen
before an American politics which is
completely untrue uh it's I don't know
if you remember a guy named Scott Walker
from Wisconsin that guy was going to be
the next president of the world and [__]
he was going to control it all he looked
like a president he talked like a
president he offended off the recall
votes he's going to be great he went to
Iowa like [__] you go back to Wisconsin
and we haven't heard from him since but
he continues to say just an average
Governor look at the stats with a with a
great PR with great PR probably lost
Maga forever so he's he's attacking Ron
DeSantis which I can't tell you text
Paul is the juiciest thing ever because
he put another post up almost
immediately he said the sanctimonious
put off his announcement until June
because his numbers were so bad
I'm just reading it like it's written
um he also got rid of ridiculous
exploratory committee quote unquote
because he didn't like what they were
telling him my God there he is with the
make America great again and again and
again it's almost like there's a video
or multiple videos of trump saying how
actually you know what I think I have a
clip okay let's pull it up let's put up
what do you what do you make of some of
these uh crazy statements uh this
morning Texas ball from Grandpa down
there at Mar-A-Lago is it it's just me
or is he freaking out
we can see it I mean that he's losing
his damn mind I mean right funny Willis
has come out and said next we're gonna
you're gonna get your indictment in in
the next cycle of the Court which is
coming up in June he's freaking out man
I mean he is completely freaking out but
the righties his followers they're
morons they love this stuff they
actually think that this has you know
some some weight behind it like you know
that you know there's something to it
when it's really just oh my God you know
I mean he's freaking the [__] out what
like you mean like the the 20
000 fake bot accounts on true social
because see that's that's my point about
the CNN thing because I get everyone's
upset about it but no one's seeing this
[__] that he's saying no one's seeing
this [__] no one watches his [__]
videos besides us and then we show the
the people who knows he's insane he's
insane like no one's watching this [__]
and really honestly keep producing it
because it's going to make great general
election ads against your dumb ass but
here he is it also goes to show you what
happened for the for the pudding ad
right right why is he making attacks
against a person who has not announced
officially they are running if you don't
actually consider them uh uh a a
candidate or an opponent or something
that you fear right you see a threat you
attack it that's how Trump works right
he sees it threat he attacks it right no
no matter who they are could be his own
[__] family members he attacks it he
sees it as a threat so if if Ron
DeSantis hasn't announced he's running
why would you know and also it's like oh
I'm not afraid of Ron DeSantis well then
why are you making ads man right well
yeah
but it's like if you're not afraid of
him why are you talking about right well
I hope Donald Trump does destroy Ryan
DeSantis now he goes on about the CNN
thing this morning he says I'll be doing
CNN blah blah blah yakety schmackity
it's great uh CNN might be the new Fox
News why not that sort of [__] and then
he he goes on to that talk about the E
Gene Carroll trial because he's got like
he's he's a caged animal and he ain't
just in one cage he's like 20 of them so
he's he's he's posting about every
single Corner he's backed into here's
another corn he's backed into with this
uh waiting this jury's decision on the E
Gene Carroll rape and defamation trial
he says waiting for a jury decision on
the false accusation where I despite
being a current political candidate
which I don't know what the [__] that
has to do with you raping her and
leading all others in the both parties
are not allowed to speak and defend
myself [__] the judge gave you a
chance [__] he goes on to say
even his hard nose or order scream
questions about this case at me
in the meantime the other side has a
book falsely accusing me of rape and is
working with the Press I will therefore
not speak until after the trial wait so
you want to speak but you're not going
to speak he says but we'll appeal the
unconstitutional Silence of me as a
candidate no matter the outcome so uh it
seems to me it gave Sanchez and and and
Texas Paul that Donald Trump here is
suspecting that in this civil case he's
going to be convicted of rape and
defamation he's got to set it up he's
gotta he's got don't you think yeah well
of course he's got to Prime his base to
say look they are probably gonna find me
guilty of this thing that I did not do
wink wink right like but he that's
that's how you do it right that's how
all these Republicans work they Prime
their base
for the situation that's going to happen
and they're going to say the reason I
didn't win or the reason I lost wait
wait wait wait wait I got news on this I
got news on this Texas Paul
um it looks like
um
could be it is going to come later today
they have
um they are deliberating on the rape and
defamation case it looks like they're
gonna have to make a decision on the the
count of of rape first and then they
move to the defamation
um have you have you have you looked at
any of what's going on and if we're
going to hear from this jury today Texas
Paul have you have you found anything on
that you know man I I would be surprised
if it was a fast verdict I really would
as you see these juries have worked
through these things before it got
thrown to the jury
great that's wonderful they're
deliberating I can't see them not at
least reviewing
trial notes I can't see them not at
least reviewing the evidence one more
time uh trying to do due diligence I
mean these
but yeah I would expect probably either
late late today maybe tomorrow but this
could deliberate this this deliberation
could go on for days it depends on how
much they want to go back and and really
be sure of themselves I mean if you
think the longer it goes the better it
is for E Gene Carroll or the opposite
you know I've heard lawyers
repeatedly tell you know that have
repeatedly said don't read into that you
don't know you don't know what they're
doing there's no oh if it's quick it you
know it could be quick because they
didn't believe [__] that the government
produced you know it could be quick
because they've already made up their
minds
um you can't really read into that I
would suspect that they're going to take
a day or two to look at the evidence
again
well here's more projection from Grandpa
this is in the last hour again he's
freaking out today on fraud social just
absolute meltdown
um he he's posting about Rupert Murdoch
uh again he says Rupert Murdoch quote
the worst Republican speaker ever Paul
Ryan what the [__] he was your speaker
dude uh Rhino Recaro now Carl Rove is a
Republican and name only Texas ball get
the [__] out of here he says the Wall
Street globalist Journal and the rapidly
disintegrating Fox News have gone all
out over the last three months pushing
and promoting Rhonda sanctimonious no
they haven't that's a [__] lie a man
who without the help endorsement of
president
he he referred to himself as Donald J
Trump president Donald J Trump would now
be working at McDonald's he's a [__]
Jag lawyer Trump he's [__] more Elite
than you are dummy
um be far away from Tallahassee anyways
all this rhino globalist push for
election undenier Murdoch has crashed
the Sanctus in the polls no Rhonda Ron
DeSantis is a [__] weirdo meatball
hand pudding finger [__] that's
the reason why Rhonda zantes is taking
the ball no one likes him because he's
unlikely [__] camera
would like Rhonda even Ron DeSantis
doesn't like Rhonda Santas so so grandpa
goes on to say here uh and I'm gonna
play the clip game here in just a minute
about Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump how
he really feels about him
um but here's the last true social that
he's posted today within the last hour
he says the Democrats of the party of
disinformation projection
um when they say something it usually
means they won the opposite
oh my God he's totally telling on
himself here don't you see it um like
the upcoming 2024 election they say they
want Trump
to be their opponent but they don't mean
it yeah we do dude we 100 want you to be
the lunatic at the Helm of the sinking
ship that's exactly what we want that's
why they are viciously
why is he capitalizing persecuting me in
every court in the land every single
Court I don't know if that's true
because I wish it was because they don't
want to run against me no we do man we
do we want you to be we want you to be a
a an indicted [__] when you run
they want anybody else also the polls
have been leading uh big against Biden
also who gives a [__] about polls I won
twice doing much better the second time
and now I'll do it a third
explain the Wall Street Journal Texas
Paul I can't tell you how much this
makes me so happy this guy is just
absolutely digging his political grave
and doesn't even know it yet doesn't
even he can't even see it that's
hilarious
the Republicans I have to tell you they
did not want to jump on this train again
they really didn't they politically
could see the writing on the wall
because if these indictments come
through with even even this civil case
with Eugene Carroll
if this doesn't go his way he is going
to burn the house to the ground good
right yeah yeah let's let and let's burn
let's burn the whole institution with it
because here he is here he is kissing
Ronda Santos's ass in this clip let's
listen how he really feels about
disemantimonious the governor like
Rhonda Sanchez Florida's doing a great
job oh yeah great play school of Florida
yeah great Governor great great Governor
great exactly what he's doing a terrific
job he just announced that the schools
will be open in the fall governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis who's done a
a spectacular job in Florida
yeah you want to see him sitting next to
each other yeah yeah Lotus that notice
the hands right look notice the posture
all the [__] same dude right all the
[__] saying she's copying him I I do
have to say that the the last couple of
videos of Rhonda Santos and I've seen
where he's in front of a Podium he's
really let down his Trump impersonation
he's not impersonating Trump anymore
yeah and I think that's the challenge
he's having because he's trying not to
act like Trump anymore but now he he's
so [__] he's such a [__] weirdo
that he doesn't even know who he is
that's why he's doing all these weird
things and it looks so weird he should
have he should have tried to I don't
know cultivate his own uh personality
well when you're [__] uh you know
composed of meatballs and chocolate
pudding you're only going to be as good
as the thing you copy right meatballs
pudding and manga and Maga Flags that's
what it is so I have we could go on and
play this yeah there's multiple clips
throughout this whole thing there's
other things
he just he props him up and says he's
great great Governor great great guy
love him got it got it gotta praise him
he's doing an excellent job really
handling Cove it's so great he didn't
but you know give it to Trump to [__]
praise somebody's a [__] idiot but
well
it was just fun it's just funny to see
him
go on the offensive and attack Ron
DeSantis despite the fact that Donald
Trump has praised Ron DeSantis
[__] again and again and how often
has Ron DeSantis kissed Donald Trump
says that's the trouble that they're in
here folks and that's why I tell you
that elections are important and the
election cycle that we're in is not the
general 2024 election the election cycle
that we're in is in the Republican
primary folks we're in the primaries and
you have to pay attention every single
weekday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast thanks for joining us
um also don't forget to go visit
realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspaul.com Texas ball you got
anything else you want to shamelessly
plug there oh man the show's going great
the audience is exploding don't forget
guys every Sunday at nine Central we'll
get together we talk about the news of
the week and any any uh anything special
that I want to dig into I always have a
round table discussion at the end join
me Sunday at nine o'clock go to
realtexaspawn.com you'll find all his
links there also don't forget to follow
us on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google do us a huge favor
and download every single one and leave
a great review on the directory that you
love best while you're there subscribing
also go to what was that show.com it'll
take you directly to Gabe Sanchez
patreon page or go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez check out what he's doing
over there with all the extras with what
was that while you're on patreon go over
to my page the Tony Michaels go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels you can
find my extras there as well for our
Support also support us on Facebook by
following us if you still have a
Facebook account at the Tony Michaels
and what you can do is link your Amazon
Prime account to your Twitch account
this is a huge way to give free money to
the Tony Michaels podcast and I say it's
free because it doesn't cost you a
single nickel if you're a prime
subscriber so if you're a prime Amazon
Prime subscriber don't forget to link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you go to Amazon gaming you go
to Amazon gaming to link those accounts
I think we're gonna make a video and put
a link or something that way you guys
have a way to figure that out some
people are having trouble but there's
more and more people subscribing but
here's the thing even if you don't have
an Amazon Prime account you can still
follow us on Twitter for absolutely free
no money zero you can follow us over on
Twitch as what I meant not Twitter
twitch follow us on Twitch and link your
Prime account to your Twitch account if
you have it and give us that one free
subscription you get
with your Prime account okay I think
I think we're over time uh Paul I
appreciate you having you here on
Tuesdays as every Tuesday it's always
good to be here great job my friend it
is so great to see you again oh thank
you don't suck up to him no I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding everyone who doesn't like me um
you know what I want to show one more
thing before we go
um someone made something yesterday and
I I thought it was so [__] cool
um can I make a pitch for you while
you're looking that up go ahead
folks what he's talking about with the
prime accounts is super important it
really is patreon is super important
because the support buying merchandise
and stuff like that is great but a
patreon account you can you can do in a
small increment
but it's a monthly that you can count on
that when you're producing one of these
shows you have monthly expenses that
come they're very regular the support is
not the support if you ask Tony we'll
tell you some you know it's either filet
mignon or peanut butter you know you
never know patreon makes everything
stable
assigning your assigning your your
Amazon Plus uh your your Amazon Prime
accounts on Twitch makes that's a stable
donation that shows like Tony's can work
from it's super important folks it
really is what I want to thank everyone
who re-subscribed today because you also
have to do that is resubscribe every
month and the people who have subscribed
today and linked their Prime account to
the Twitch account and I want to thank
Nate
um over on
Twitter he made this it's dark Tony
um someone last week said I was in the
comments on one of the shows
um is a new listener I forget the name
offhand
um but someone said this show reminds
them of Rush Limbaugh but to the left
you know I was saying the opposite and
they said maybe it's dark Limbaugh I
said I'll take it dark Limbaugh I'll
take it but Nate made Nate had AI make
dark Tony it must have pulled images off
the internet uh of my longer hair than
my shorter hair but I thought it was
cool so I wanted to give Nate a shout
out thanks Nate for for having AI make
the uh the dark Tony there and everybody
same time same place tomorrow you know
where to find us Surfside [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
foreign
[Music]